the minute he left that studio I rang
everyone and said this guy is a
superstar but then three years ago I've
never told anyone this story three years
ago
BBC Radio and extra for the biggest
Rapture on the planet
I was raised in an environment where not
many people ever amounted to anything
it's not our fault it's society's fault
[ __ ] Society
so it was tough we was living in a shed
my son had just been born I couldn't
afford nappies now we had no toilet that
was the sacrifice that I had to make in
order for me to become the person I
needed to become fire in the booth
Brandon has always been so integral for
me it's a fire in the booth brand became
a monster within the culture there's not
many people like me that understand
culture and understand business in the
same way I do Au vodka is a great
reflection of that we outsold Gray Goose
twice over three times as many bottles
of syrup turnover 80 million pounds this
year you're joking no how much do you
think this is valued at now 800 million
Jesus Christ we actually have a Bible to
do's and don'ts everyone wants to know
what's in that Bible ah what kind of
things are in there I mean it goes from
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode
foreign
[Music]
I'm a big believer on this podcast that
our earliest years end up defining who
we become and shaping who we are from a
character standpoint our perspective on
the world what we think matters our
values and all of those things and
really decides which way we go off into
the world and how we go off into the
world
when I was reading about your early
years
that felt more evident in this case than
in the case of most guests I sit here
with so can you tell me in those
earliest years when you look back as an
adult now what were the things what was
the context that ended up shaping you
and who you went on to become in your
life I think for me
um
coming from the humble beginnings that I
did I feel like
I was raised in an environment where not
many people ever amounted to anything
so there was no one for me growing up
who I looked up to as a role model per
se it was more you know
family members for me that gave me the
confidence and inspiration to do better
in life but I feel at the same time me
coming from that environment
colored me and toughened me to become
almost I felt like growing up Invincible
because you know growing up seeing
friends get killed go to prison when you
survive that
it almost makes you feel like wow
I'm indestructible especially at a young
age and I've always been very confident
and had loads of self-belief but I feel
like it set me up to wanna a prove
people wrong because I felt like I was
never given any opportunities or chances
to you know better myself or be the
person I am today you know when I was 17
I didn't even know what university was I
had no idea what university was when you
think about that now and put that into
perspective that's crazy I had no idea
what university was when I was younger
I wanted to be a director I wanted to
make movies
and I never had no insight into how that
made that how to make that happen my
teachers were like you'll be a plumber
electrician
or a chippy at best
if you do well so for me I was kind of
like huh there's got to be more to life
than that and I was always very
inquisitive I always wanted to know how
things worked or why things didn't work
or how how you do this and how you do
that I was always very up on
self-education so I feel like those
early years of my life really shaped who
I am today you know how I treat other
people
because obviously my mom was the cleaner
so you know when I'm in a corporate
building or you know
wherever I am in the world I'd always
treat that person with the same respect
that I'll treat the CEO that I meet in
that day or that I'm doing business with
that day because that cleaner was my mum
so I have a different View and
perspective on life and on people and I
think that's put me you know in a great
position in life especially with my
people skills and how to treat people
which I feel is a massive part of why I
am where I am
what about your father
my father was an electrician very strict
very very strict man very disciplined
and as a young as as a young kid you
know we didn't always see eye to eye
um and I always felt like he like failed
my sisters and he would always make
comments to me you'll never be as
successful as I am
and as a kid I'm like whoa like we're
talking about that and it's mad this is
a funny story my dad used to always say
that to me you'll never be as successful
as I am
and as a child I always thought that
he meant in terms of
monetary
success that's what I viewed as success
but then three years ago I've never told
anyone a story three years ago
I took my family away my whole family
for Christmas
and me and my dad had a drink and I'm
like
that like just look around you Dad
look at everything that I've got
and everything that I've achieved
you said I'll never be as successful as
you
and he said to me son
I was never talking about money
's never been a thing for me I've never
chased money in the same way you chase
money
I was talking about you
and your sisters and your mother
stop and I'm like what are you talking
about that
and he said look at the man you've
become
look at the women your sisters have
become
I am successful
as a father
you're all winners and it's true me and
my sisters we're all winners
like my sister's got an incredible job
my youngest has got an incredible job I
couldn't have a business I can't help
but think you you beat him so he moved
the goal posts maybe maybe maybe but
that's pretty good at that 21st but it
made me think it made me stop because
I've always to be fair I've always used
that as motivation without even knowing
it and to that point I never really
assessed the situation in a way that I
should have because I'll always use that
to drive me on to be like
come on dad now I'm light years ahead
without having that conversation having
that conversation with myself in my head
and so I had that conversation I didn't
really sit down and
read deep why I was thinking like that
and I think it almost there was a way
that lifted from my shoulders once I'd
had that conversation I think likewise
for my dad you know
um like I think it's like it changed the
Dynamics of our relationship somewhat
but when I do look back at the things
that he would say and the things that he
would do he was like a coach like the
ultimate coach
you know like he he would Inspire and
motivate me without pampering me without
making me soft he would say things that
he knew was harsh or he would discipline
me in ways that he knew were harsh and
he probably felt bad about the time but
he had a plan for how he wanted me to
turn out
and you know Look At Me Now and he
played a big part of it
what about money when people come from
backgrounds I mean you grew up in a
council estate right when people come
from those backgrounds and money is a
center point of like the relationships
in the household it's the the cause of
the argument it's everything right it's
always there in a conversation when we
become adults we can sometimes have like
an unhealthy pursuit or relationship
with money it can control our decision
making a little bit too much so as it
relates to your relationship with money
at that point
growing up and how that kind of
orientated you as you became a young man
what was your relationship with money I
think for me money was a necessity
if we didn't have money
or if I didn't make money additional
money for my family home we never had
gas we never had electric we never had
food and growing up for me
I was like this can't happen I need to
change this I need to make effort myself
not rely on my parents or my sisters to
get out of my way and change this and
from a young age I was
I was always about you know from when I
was 12 to up until I was 17. I was
always about making money and that for
me was the drive how do I make money I
need to make more money you know it
started with me selling sandwiches
because
I couldn't afford lunch dinners I
weren't getting free dinners at the time
um so my mom used to make me a pack
lunch
and I remember going to school seeing
the sandwiches sitting the crisp sitting
the drink making a Fiverr and I was like
wait a minute
I could just replicate this since I
started going buying a loaf of bread
salami some salad cream some lettuce and
I started making 10 sandwiches selling
all the sandwiches
and then throughout a two-year period it
it extended to me buying cigarettes
buying 20 cigarettes and selling the
cigarettes for a pound each
sometimes five pound depending on how
desperate the person who was who's
trying to buy the cigarette for me and I
would always
save the money that I'd make and
reinvest it to make more money and then
by the time I was
I say 21
my idea of chasing money had changed
somewhat
it it became very apparent for me that I
weren't happy
chasing money
I weren't about chasing the money I
still understood the value of money and
knew how important it was for me to make
money but I made a decision around 2021
that I was gonna focus on something that
I loved and that I was very passionate
about and allowed the financial rewards
to follow that rather than doing it the
other way around chasing the money by
doing things that I'm not so passionate
about I don't really care about and I
can't see it ever making me happy
before that point I was reading about
your your running with the law yeah and
it's pretty pretty severe yeah I mean
where I grew up you know
as I said it was tough and I made a lot
of bad decisions as a kid I was watching
tablets yeah a lot of that was bravado
and that show a lot of that was bravado
at a time where I felt like I had to
portray a certain image to be accepted
in a community that I felt like that was
the cool thing
to do and the cool way to act a lot of
that was bravado was there any truth to
any of that I mean there was there was
some elements of Truth to some of the
things that I got caught up in as a kid
um that you know I regret and I live
with that regret every day of my life
but
again you know I was a product of my
environment and I'm lucky enough that I
was able to escape that environment to
become the man I am today and going back
to what I was saying before all of these
incidents have shaped me to become the
person I am today so of course I regret
a lot of the things that I got caught up
in as a child and there I was a child I
wasn't a man at any point when you look
back at that kid in that documentary
Town block dreams I'm embarrassed really
yeah I cringe I can't watch it I cringe
but at the same time
there's a certain
there's a certain amount of warmth that
I feel just watching how much I've
progressed and grown as a man and to
look back at that now
for me it's just like wow wow but at the
same time I feel like you know the
amount of messages that I get every day
about
how inspiring that is to people that are
living in certain circumstances very
familiar to those that I was living in
back then and I feel like it shows
a generation for me that right now seems
very lost
very scared
very confused
that is possible that if you believe in
yourself and you apply yourself and you
put everything that's expected of you to
decide and just
do what feels right for you
anything's possible and I'm living proof
of that like I'm here today you know one
of the most successful hip-hop DJs in
Europe
I own multiple brands
and I'm still doing what I love when I
was told
that that wasn't possible
when I watch these videos outside of the
bravado
um which you you described there what I
did see was a young man that was
incredibly hungry yeah it was as you say
it's someone that was trying to change
their life in fact I I went to a prison
the other day and spent like five or six
hours in the prison talking to the
inmates and I saw the same kind of like
ambitious kind of
desperation to get out of that situation
and to turn things around and that's
what I saw in that young man was outside
of all that stuff there was a man there
that really really wanted to be
successful and really wanted to get on
and it's so funny because you say like
it was you didn't have the ideas nobody
had given you the ideas your environment
hadn't given you the ideas you didn't
even know what university was I had no
idea at that point I had no idea and
when you think about that that's bizarre
how how does a 17 year old young man not
know what university is and that's
because nobody had told me and none of
my friends were going to University I
didn't know one person that had gone to
University at that age goes to show how
much information is a privilege oh of
course the information is everything and
of course at that at that time there was
no internet so for me to self-educate in
the way I do now it wasn't possible back
then but yeah you're right my hunger and
passion was there and I feel like that's
what set me apart you know there's times
when
I've sat there and I'm always my work my
own worst critic I'll always review
myself and I'll sit there and
I wouldn't say I meditate but I like to
reflect I like to look within to find
out what I'm doing right what I'm not
doing so well
and just where I'm at in life in terms
of perspective
and there was a time maybe three years
ago
when I was sat there
and I'm questioning myself almost I'm
like you know
what is it
that's made me become the person I am
like why have I been so successful is it
luck have I just been lucky I'm asking
myself these questions
and then you know I'm thinking about my
old friendship groups and where a lot of
those are in terms of life and
so my new friendship groups
and after reflecting for several hours
and sitting there and questioning myself
the one thing that was very clear that
separated me from everyone
that I'd met throughout life and had
been part of my journey
was my self-belief
like I've always believed that
impossible is nothing
I can do it
as long as I've had that mindset about
things I've been able to accomplish it
and
part of that same
you know analysis on myself
was going back to the imagery that I'd
put up around in my studio and how I
went about achieving those certain goals
and targets that I set myself
and
it was almost
like I had achieved those things
subconsciously
for me like I had set myself a Target
and they were there was all around my
room
but I wouldn't sit there every day
thinking
I want an orange Porsche Porsche I won a
massive
um detached house with land I didn't sit
there and think every day about those
things but they they were around me and
they were part of my environment and in
the same way when I was younger my
environment had a huge influence on who
I was and how I behaved
once I stepped out of that and created
my own environment my own
Universe if you like which I was
surrounded by all of these things that I
wanted to achieve
I started achieving them
subconsciously unknowingly
without having a real
formula to how I'd achieved them so I'm
sitting there thinking wait a minute so
how how did I actually do that
and then it always comes back to the
self-belief
because the moment I believe in
something if I can visit visualize what
I'm trying to achieve I know it's
possible
the analogy that I've come to like
really believe in based on having these
conversations with people who have all
to some degree subconsciously because
you're saying that I didn't consciously
sit there every day and think about it
and make a plan it was just in my
subconscious some some I drove towards
it is this this analogy of the car right
the sat nav and and the and the pedal
you've got to set the sat nav and you've
got to push the pedal if you do one of
them if you just push the pedal I love
lost that's a great analogy if you set
the sat nav but don't push the pedal
you're going to be in your garage all
day I love that you know I mean in that
and you did both clearly you had the
drive to push the pedal but you also
knew the direction of travel you wanted
to go in in those early years though I
was watching a talk you did uh I think
it was on the BBC's channel to a group
of what looked like students about
living in a shed yeah and then your
manager giving you some advice yeah take
me back to that period of your life was
that the the toughest moment of your
YouTube I say so it was a period of my
life where I just
um
become a father
and
my
partner
was from a very very different world to
me uh family where you know you could
say middle class
and
I was in a transitioning period in my
life where I got to that point where I
was like I'm gonna do something that I
love
and something that I'm passionate about
and if I'm as good as I believe I am
the success will follow and for me it
was the success that I was chasing
rather than the money at that time I
just wanted to be the best I just wanted
to win I knew that if I won the money
would come and I'm not going to sit here
and say it was never about the money
because of course it's always about the
money anyone who says that you should
never trust them but for me
it wasn't primary it wasn't
it wasn't what was driving me forward it
was the win that was driving me forward
and I knew the money would follow
and I couldn't wait for the money to
follow but I knew it would as long as I
focused on being the best
but at that time
was living in a shed that had no
sanitation my son had just been born
and there were times when
I couldn't afford nappies
and milk
um and I was kind of doing what I could
to get by and at that time because I had
self-educated on all aspects of New
Media like I really went in like really
really went in
um I was editing
I was editing content
um
for jump off TV
and that was kind of tie me over and you
know
giving me enough money to get by
you know like we still had to
go elsewhere to shower
and use the toilet which is crazy when I
think about it now is crazy but you know
like I look back at those moments now
and that was sacrifice for me that was
the sacrifice that I had to make and I
had to put my family through
in order for me to become the person I
needed to become how are you feeling
every day when you look over at your
your family in that shed what what's
going on in your head I'm embarrassed
I am like scared
anxiety was a big thing for me
uh a lot of self-doubt I'm questioning
myself can I really do this
am I really the person that I think I am
I being selfish
should I just go and get a job
should I just give in and go and get a
nine to five
and just
submit
to being
part of the 98 percent
and for me
I just couldn't there was something
inside me that wouldn't let me that it
was almost like a voice in my head when
I look back you can do this man you've
got this and I bet I can't I can't I
almost fought a pressure and the moment
my son was born
that pressure intensified like something
I have never felt before like something
I didn't even know was possible
the the drive and the ambition I was
like I it's not about letting me down
all my parents down
I can't let my son down and there's no
way in a million years that I'm gonna
let this young man down
no way and at that point I was working
not 18 sometimes 20 hours a day every
day seven days a week I won't even spend
the time
with my family because I was just so
engrossed so obsessed with becoming the
best and creating something that moved
the needle and in my head I always knew
I'd never moved the needle
unless I was willing to move the needle
and that's what it was for me so I'd
wake up every day at 5am and in my head
I've got a four hour Head Start before
anyone's even started work I'm four
hours up on you I've got no distractions
no emails no phone calls no texts four
hours just focusing doing what I needed
to do and then I had the rest of the day
for everyone to play catch up and that's
what I was doing on my head and there
were times over a two-year period this
was there were times when
you know
people are sitting down and saying
this ain't never going to happen Charlie
it's just not going to happen
like you need to be a realist
and their doubt almost made me doubt
myself even more
but
I knew that if I kept putting in the
effort
and the work that I was putting in at
that period in my life something was
going to give and it did now this is
you know when YouTube first started very
fresh people were doing the vlogs
and
my manager at the time was saying go do
a vlog let everyone see your personality
people fall in love with you and I'm
like no way that is so corny everyone's
doing it everyone's doing it and from a
young age my thing will always be
disruptive be as noisy and as loud and
as different as you can possibly be and
I still to this very day apply that to
everything I'm doing
so I was like no no I can't do a vlog
everyone's doing it I'm just gonna be
like everyone else I need to do
something different
so
we came up with um being Charlie sloth
where at the time I played like seven
eight different characters in a show
all wore different outfits different
uniforms or their own personality
um so you had the cameraman the editor
the manager the street team the artists
uh the web designer and they each played
on stereotypes of what I felt those
person those people were
and um
I made the first episode and I spent
ages on it so long because I wrote it
myself I filmed it myself I edited
myself and we put it out on YouTube
and it done a few thousand views hours
I remember the feeling I can still I can
almost feel
the feeling of disappointment that I
felt
24 hours after that going Live on
YouTube thinking like wow I've just
spent all that time making this
after the first episode was like 40
minutes long
and
it's genius I'm thinking no one's ever
done anything like this
and nobody's watching it and I thought
you know what this may be the sign that
I needed to actually
call it a day
I was so disheartened
and
the next thing you know
be get a message
from worldstarhiphop.com saying that
they wanted to take it on exclusively
and that was a huge huge defining moment
in my life
and in my career
because not only did it give me the
break that I needed within the industry
but it also
gave me this new lease of life in terms
of self-belief and made me
understand that the work and self-belief
that I'd had in myself wasn't a waste of
time
and that there are people paying
attention around the world even when you
think people ain't looking
they are
and for me I feel like
that really changed my outlook on life
and on myself and from there there was
no looking back like beast mode was
fully activated and there was nothing
and no one that was going to stop me you
know what's really interesting is when
we think about self-belief the
self-belief you had we almost assume
that it can't exist in the same place as
doubt
but it completely rang true for me that
I I was such a self-believing person I
think the most self-believing person I'd
met when I was you know the early stages
of my career but at the same time when I
look at my diary because you know we'll
recount these stories in hindsight to
say I had so much self-belief I was
dinner I knew exactly where I was going
and it happened whereas when I look at
my diary I could see the self self-doubt
yeah and it was it come from other
people they're like maybe they're right
that that voice of like maybe they're
right you know a lot of people that are
successful I speak to
I think it's hard for a lot of people to
admit that they doubted themselves at
some point on their Journey
still doubt myself today
there's still times when even though
I've achieved some incredible things
throughout my career
I still doubt myself but that's the
pessimist in me that gives me balance I
feel like if I never had that I feel
like that self-belief could almost turn
into arrogance
and that's something that I've never
wanted to happen so I feel like when I
chat to people especially people that
are grounded it feels like that's a
safety mechanism that we install in
ourselves and program in our minds to
keep ourselves grounded and humble
because anytime I spoke to people that
don't really have that or don't really
want to admit self-doubt
they're the ones that are bordering
on the line of arrogance
those people typically tend to come from
a slightly different background to yours
as well I think because you know if
you're grown up in a family where
everyone was a billionaire yeah you
saying that you want to do this or this
people like easy Charlie
I'll connect you to the guy now yeah but
growing up in that background you're
constantly nobody's doing what you want
to do you're confronted with with um
that negative pessimism because that's
what people feel about themselves around
you why could you do that how can you
become that person you know I've never
they don't live around here when I came
up Jamal for me was the the only was the
black guy that had made become
successful in business I stalked that
kid on Skype I told him years later when
we became friends like you were the
bridge
and when kids come from your background
they don't have that bridge I think it's
it's a shame
it's a massive shame and you still see
it today I mean you know but that's
again that's that's
being from that environment
you know no one wants the working class
to be inspired no one wants to work in
class to believe that they don't have to
be working class this is a choice
you know like it's it's from a young age
is programmed in us from our parents
you know that this is what you have to
do
to have a good life you have to go to
school then you go to college if you're
lucky
you can go to university then you get a
job then you find a partner then you get
a mortgage then you're trapped and then
that's it
the moment you enter that agreement with
the bank
is the moment
you're trapped in my opinion there's no
you can't really Escape at that point
because you have commitments you now
have to go to work
to pay that mortgage every month and
it's at that point where you become a
part of the system
and the sad thing is most of the working
class youth of today don't know any
better and that's why you find a lot of
the kids from that environment looking
up to
the drug dealers
the fraud guys because they're the only
guys that I've ever seen financial
success in those communities so they're
not going to look up to a doctor or a
lawyer or a dentist because there are
none the moment that
shifts
is the moment the mentality of our kids
or this generation will change and I
think it's changed slightly now because
obviously the internet has given
everyone a much broader Vision in terms
of what's possible but there's still a
lot of the youth that don't really use
the internet in that way and when you
think about that
that's insane there's still a lot of
families that haven't got
a computer or a tablet at home and this
is a real thing you know I spend a lot
of time doing things in with the youth
and trying to give back and trying to
inspire and encourage the Next
Generation and some of the conversations
that I have I'm just like whoa
how to
come by this get an iPad go and get him
an iPad right now it's it's mind-blowing
it's mind-blowing on that point of you
know seeds
planted seeds I think your story is the
most perfect examples of how seeds you
plant can end up changing your life not
just for you but all the seeds that were
planted on your platform that changed
lives yeah and we'd like I see it here
so often with people who tell you know
who gold medal Olympians or they've got
bit hundred billion dollar company
whatever it is and you see at some point
they planted some seed without really
knowing what the consequence would be
and maybe three years later maybe five
minutes later that seed unexpectedly
changes their life that day when you
started making being Charlie sloth and
it went on WorldstarHipHop for anybody
that doesn't know WorldStarHipHop
because maybe you're so young or you
just you're not been watching World Star
Wars the cultural hip-hop website of my
whole childhood yeah the biggest in the
world yeah it was like YouTube it was
like YouTube yeah it was like YouTube
for the rap market and they picked the
videos that went on there so you
couldn't just upload it yourself
um it was the biggest millions and
millions of views um you're getting a
week on that on that platform when you
when you eventually when they found you
but that idea of planting seeds you must
have seen that over and over again oh
for sure in the beef for sure for sure I
mean like you know initially
you know that was a massive Crossroad in
my career do I go back into what my
passion was you know music
producing DJing or do I stay on this
road
of being childish love which is
ultimately
it's in stroke comedy if you like
um and it was because I could see the
potential in the platform at BBC one
extra
that I made that decision and it wasn't
so much about me and that when I look
back at that now that I was very
selfless because I could have taken a
big check at the time
but this goes back to again what I was
saying it weren't about the money I
could have taken that check and I don't
know where I'd be now
but being the man that I was with money
I've always been very good of money I
would have I would have made that money
into more money
but I was like it's not about that this
is about the next 10 years and what can
I do not only for me but for the
community the bbcc the World Star videos
how did that they saw the world start so
it was actually DJ sentix ah okay um
great friend of mine uh great one of my
peers someone who I've always looked up
to and respected
um he was going on tour with Dizzy
Rascal on World Tour and needed someone
to cover his show
so he got me and Retreat too to come and
cover the show so me and rech covered I
believe it was five or six shows and
then you know the response was insane
that they offered me and Retreat to our
own show
so they offered a show to me and Rich
fee too and me and Rich spoke about it
and we was like it's a no-brainer let's
do it so we agree terms with the BBC
and the night before
they was going to annoy it
wretch called me at early hours in the
morning he's like Charlie I've been
thinking about this non-stop I'm like
what's that
it's like I'm not going to do the radio
show bro ah what he's like bro I hope
this don't mess things up for you but I
really believe that I can crack this
music thing
so I was like bro I wish you all the
best look man I'm just gonna go and do
the LA thing they're being chai slothing
bro kill the music so he's like ah
thanks bro it means a lot so the next
day abuse you around me there's like ah
you know Rex don't want to do it
probably won't work with just you on
your own so I was like cool like for me
there's no skin off my back I'm like I'm
doing this being shy stuff I'm getting
millions of views all the American
rappers know me they all want to do
stuff I'm kind of like cool BBC is cool
even at the time in my head I was like I
can do so much here I can I can really
move the needle like no one has you'd
already start dreaming I started putting
things in place in my head and planning
so I was like it's cool don't worry
and then a few days later uh Rebecca
Frank ran me back she's like listen
um I've had a chat with a with a
management and I've convinced him that
you can do it do you still want to do it
and in my mind I'm like
yeah I do
so bad but obviously my team at the time
were all set on
going to Stateside it's just got my 0-1
Visa I'm you know ready to go and um
I said yeah you know what let's do it
but I didn't tell my team
and it went into the Anna winner that
they were like how are you going to do
this it's impossible and I was like well
I'm actually going to do the radio thing
and I'm not going to do the being
Charlie sloughing
and obviously they're like you are
insane have you lost your marbles at the
time
when I first joined the BBC
I was getting
a hundred and forty pound I believe a
show
so I was only earning
140 pounds a week
working for the BBC so when you think
about that even when I think about that
now
you know there's this huge perception
and illusion that DJs own
ridiculous amounts of money now they do
I mean let's be fair you know I've done
all right and there's other DJs that
Trump me
um by the time you know go and accepting
and uh contract
a year contract at a time for 140 pound
a week you know to go and be on the BBC
rather than
a six-figure deal
in LA
I think most people especially you know
managers in general are very straight
thinking yeah right yeah and it's all
about the money it's very straight
thinking
it's it's bad you do that because
there's more money involved but for me
I'm looking about I'm looking at the big
picture and I knew what I was capable of
bringing to the table and in my mind I'm
sat there and I'm thinking before I even
started I'm looking at my right what
components of a radio show live within a
radio show and make people come to the
radio show to listen but also have a
life outside of the radio show and
continue living
and continue bringing new listeners to
the show while growing outside
and I was like freestyles
so I was like well I'm just gonna brand
ultimately what has been happening
within the culture for years
but make it a brand but it has to be a
brand that stands and lives within
within the community which solves a
problem
which gives artists from the UK from a
street level a platform to Showcase
their talent
but also means something to the culture
something to look up to something to
inspire them something to work towards
if you're an artist
and that's where Friday Booth came from
and
you know I feel like you know
understanding the power of branding
is what put that in a position that it
still is today of course it's not the
brand that is carried for any Booth it's
the talent
the final Booth brand is just a conduit
but a conduit that's trusted a conduit
that you know is not going to Peddle you
artists because the Brand's being paid
to a a product that is
positioned within the community to serve
the community I think the Integrity of
find a booth
can never be questioned you know I still
I see people now I finally we've done
it's finished and I read those comments
and I laugh to myself because
I've been through that Friday Booth is
done final Booth is finished
three or four times understanding the
cycles and understanding what's
happening and repositioning the brand so
it never dies
and the final brief brand will be a
around as long as I'm here or there's
someone else who cares as much as me
about the culture
so you know there was times when a new
freestyle platform will come up and be
doing more traffic more views
find a Boost done a year later a moment
that we've been planning for 18 months
will happen fine the booth is the best
that no one else can get these guys on
Friday Booth I trade you no Drake and
there's been you know multiple juice
World little baby yeah you know there's
been so many moments where we've had
moments of artists that were special
moments pop smoke that you don't really
get anywhere else that are just very
unique and raw
unpolished so yeah I feel like that the
fire in the booth brand became like a
monster within the culture and you know
we have never ever ever taken a penny of
any artist to perform on there I've
never taken a check from a label to make
sure that artist is positioned right or
never and because for me
that's what makes final Booth so special
when it comes to building a brand that
has Integrity yeah
what matters you know this is a brand
yeah and I think it has Integrity but I
think because you have integrity I think
because you have integrity you install
your morals into the brand and this
brand is a reflection of you I feel like
pretty much
everything you do speaks about you as a
person because
I feel like I'm the same I feel like if
it challenged my morals
I wouldn't want to do it because I'd be
like well that's that's not a real
reflection of me why am I going to
invest my time or my money my energy
into something that doesn't represent me
and I feel like my team
you know I have an amazing team do an
incredible job of managing the
expectations of all of the brands that
I'm involved with and I don't even have
to say it no more if if I feel like
something's wrong or
it's not going to work it doesn't look
right for the brand they know before
it's even come to me because they know
what my morals are they know what I
stand for what I don't stand for what I
feel is right so it's got to the point
where I don't even have to have those
conversations because I have such a
great team who had those conversations
for me and they protect the brand I feel
like if something goes wrong with one of
the brands it's a reflection on me and
something that I've always
believed is one of my biggest assets
is my reputation
I feel like you may not like me
you may hate me you might find me
annoying but one thing you can't
challenge is my reputation I've never
done any one day ever I've never
backstabbed anyone I've never said I'm
gonna do something I've not done it
and my brands have to hold up that same
ethos in order for your team to know
what decisions you'd make before you
know it even comes to you as it relates
to The Branding the positioning of it
and all those things that must first
start with you being really really clear
and what I've got from all of that is
because you're so clear in your head and
non-negotiable about what this brand is
you've been able to kind of like install
that in all of the people around you so
now they are like Disciples of the
values for sure well we actually have a
Bible oh really we actually have a fire
and a brief Bible a handbook to do's and
don'ts and especially now because you
know the vision of fire in the booth
has gone from being uh
a feature on a radio show to being a
global brand you know obviously now
we're with Apple
you know one of the biggest companies in
the world who I believe share the same
ethos as we do in terms of vision in
terms of content consumption
and
I feel like now the brand really is
going global everyone wants to know
what's in that Bible ah what kind of
things are in there I mean it's you know
it goes from camera setup yeah to edits
colors to use
um
right through to
um how artists are treated once they're
once they arrive communication with
teams
um one of the things I found really
interesting is I read that you deleted
potentially hundreds of episodes of fire
in the booth that just didn't cut it
yeah which which I think a lot of people
would be surprised by because you know a
rapper an artist comes down they perform
they might think it's gone off they
might think that you know they killed it
and then you're sat there thinking this
doesn't meet the standard yeah I feel
like you know I feel there's times when
I'm not ready to find a booth and an
artist later on has gone on to thank me
because
you know it's a big moment in an
artist's career and I feel like if it
doesn't do you justice it's not about me
it's not about what I think this is
going to do well for the final Booth
brand
like anytime I have a conversation with
an artist and they say to me do you
think it's good I can't sit there and
lie to the artist face and say yes it's
okay I'm gonna be like you could do
better
if you want to come back and go again we
can if not let's just park it off for
now and come back to it at a later date
and there's been so many that have not
gone out but that's because I felt it's
not a good reflection on them not on the
brand because No One's Gonna you know
attack the brand as much as they would
the artist there's one of the biggest
artists in the world right now Stephen
one of the biggest globally
right you come in to do a final booth
and I can't tell you how excited I was
for this moment even though it was a few
years ago there was still a big artist
then but they weren't us because they
are now
and they came in and done their final
booth and you know we everyone was
excited and we was prepared for it
and they came in and it was possibly
one of the worst fine abuse I've ever
recorded
and I could see that the artist was
quite excited
by their performance
and you know they was like oh when when
we're going to release it and in my mind
I'm thinking is this just me is it
because I expected here
and they delivered here that I'm judging
this and they're talking to me and
they're Mars just moving and I'm
processing all this information in my
head because I'm like I don't want to
lie to the artist I don't want to be
disrespectful to The Host
all this information sweating on my head
and I was like
I'm going to go back and listen to the
final booth uh give me 10 minutes so I
went back into the studio we played it
ah this is garbage
this is garbage
so I chatted the producer at the time I
was like how how's best to handle the
situation
I don't want to go out and say that this
is not going to go out but at the same
time I want to give them the opportunity
to redo it while they're here while
they're in the country
and
regretfully
I didn't do that
I didn't go out and give the artist the
opportunity to do it again
I was like you know what I'm just gonna
say
that it's not going out
and
for me that was a bad decision I look
back at that now and it's a bad decision
um but it just weren't good enough it
weren't good enough and there's so many
artists that I've come through and not
performed but again like I said some
that have called me I let it down said
you know what I appreciate you not
putting that final Booth out
let's go again why do you regret that
decision
because
in hindsight
I could have given them the opportunity
to record that again there and then but
because I had no faith in the situation
I was like I'm not going to waste their
time and I'm not going to waste my
team's time I just think it's best that
we kind of keep it moving
but now
on reflection I should have given them
the opportunity to do it again
you know and his comments all the time
I've spoke about this before where
people like release it
released the final Booth this person is
huge right now we've got sign off on it
we can release it
but I just wouldn't you know like I'm I
don't I don't do things for that reason
I'm not gonna [ __ ] on the artist now we
put something out that I thought was
[ __ ] back then for you and put it out
now for views it's counterproductive it
goes against everything that I say and
stand for so it will never come out I
would probably wouldn't even say the
person's name I'll tell you off camera
okay I I have some a slightly similar
story that I record an episode of the
diversia with the person who's currently
if there's three biggest YouTubers in
the world he's he's definitely one of
them oh wow and I just never put it out
because it just the conversation is so
dead are you serious it's so dead it
just doesn't go anywhere and it like
I've blamed myself in part for like not
being able to get anything from them
um and in this same situation they were
they weren't as big then as they are now
now they're one of the biggest and I
just but I look reflect on conversation
I know I said like how do I stop that
happening in the future because this you
know I play a role in the content
whereas in firing the booth you play a
role but it's you'll creating a platform
for them to show them their talent
whereas I feel like you've got to lead
it yeah I feel like I could have done
better a better job I was so inspired
watching your conversation with Adam
where you say about the that board
meeting with with the BBC at the start
where you you lay out to them that you
what you're going to do yeah as a DJ did
anybody believe you what did you say no
definitely not I didn't really I think I
I feel like I got lost out of the room
at the time so it was two the two bosses
at the time and I'd gone in to do my
paperwork and
you know it was like so you know what
are your aspirations what are you trying
to achieve here why are you at BBC I
said well within a month I'll create the
biggest online freestyle platform
that'll do millions of views like great
yeah
it's not radio that's not radio Charles
I'll just let you know that's that's not
radio that's YouTube I'm like me and
then I said secondly I replaced Westwood
I'll take all of Westwood shows within
five years and one of the guys actually
laughed in my face
I said excuse me why are you laughing
he said oh do you know how many times
I've heard that
and I said well you've never heard it
from me
and he's like good like good luck with
that chap good luck so I was like okay
so it actually took me three years
of being at the BBC to replace Westwood
and all of these shows so that was six
radio shows a week
um
and I said it would take me five
so I remember this is a great story I
actually saw the guy a few weeks back we
laughed over it
you know I I got the call to say where
there's going to be an Anno Guyana today
announcing all staff that you're
replacing Westwood on all shows as of
set date
here we go now at midday today
so I was like perfect
so I left my house nice and early
went into uh the BBC building
and went around to this guy's desk at
it must have been 11 55
sat on the edge of his desk and just
waited for that inbox to light up with
an all staff from the boss
12 o'clock it drops in
he opens it looks at me
it says fair play you did it
fair play what can I say how's that
thank you
I said I'll do it in five I did it in
three
it reminds me of you the comments what
your dad was saying she was naked as
well for sure and those things you know
and two
into you unwrap it and unravel it you
don't really understand what impact is
had on your life I feel like those small
moments
that drive you on and and give you that
fuel to keep pushing through
there sat at the back of your mind and
then once you've achieved that goal or
you know Something's Happened around
that conversation when you can really
dissect it and really get into the the
nitty-gritty of the words that were
presented to you that have inspired and
motivated you to become better you're
like wow okay it's bizarre but yeah it
was a big moment for me that the
interpretation going on there is the key
thing right because your dad's words
that guy's words any words of self-doubt
can be interpreted in many ways
depending on the mind that's
interpreting them so with your dad's
comments that could have made someone go
[ __ ] I'm not good enough I'll just I'll
just yeah I want to crash and chill I'm
gonna crash and chill whereas you you
almost interpret it as like you still
probably interpret it as like I'm not
good enough but
I'm going to prove to you that I am yeah
and I think that's such an interesting
thing because from this podcast I used
to think people that were driven or
successful which is these people that
were like super motivated and whatever
else well I've come to learn the more
episodes we've done is that nearly all
of them start with this complex they're
fighting against which is you're not
good enough dude you know what for a
long time
I lived with that and especially when I
started stepping into board meetings
um meeting corporate folk I felt like I
was dismissed because of how I spoke how
I dressed but for me
I always thought you know what
you all know better than me because of
your background or where you are in life
so why would you judge me for being who
I am even though I I've worked hard
enough to sit at the same table as you
and that would eat me up for a long time
and I'd never speak about it it was you
know it was I guess a class complex
if anything I felt like a lot of people
judged me
um on the way I've spoken and wear dress
without actually getting to know me or
or picking my brain and actually to be
totally honest I think it wasn't until
Maybe
five years ago where I got past that
I was like you know what I deserve to be
at this table and you should be humbled
and grateful that I'm sat at this table
willing to give you some of the
information that I have because if you
had the information that I have I won't
be sat at this table
you wouldn't need me to be side this
table and you probably wouldn't want me
to be sat at this table and that's how I
think I think
I understand the value that I bring to
every situation that I'm in now and that
self-doubt has been totally removed
still self-doubt in my life but in terms
of who I am and what I bring to the
table and what I'm capable of achieving
I feel like I'm in a very unique Lane in
life there's not many people like me
that understand culture
and understand business in the same way
I do it's so funny because being Charlie
sloth in more ways than one not just the
documentary you started but throughout
your career and being your authentic
self in in situations where you might
not have fit the status quo it's so
clearly to me one of the key reasons why
you're successful like being yourself
yeah right so it's interesting to hear
that someone who from the outside
everyone will go well we Charlie's lost
his child is off because he's Charlie
sloth yeah right would also go no I had
those moments walking into rooms where I
thought
in fact I don't belong or are they
judging me or you know yeah for sure if
I felt inferior I felt like
should I really be at this table should
I be speaking different dressing yeah
and there was time there was times in my
life when I would go into a meeting and
my phone voice would pop out and I'd
leave the meeting I'd be I'd be so mad
at myself like what are you doing
what are you doing why did you do that
because you felt like you had to speak a
certain way around a certain type of
person no way like and I feel like yeah
I feel like a lot of people
appreciate and respect me for being
unapologetically me you've had all these
artists come on your your platforms over
the years and with fire in the booth
you've really like without a shadow of a
doubt made people's careers and I've
always wondered
what is it that makes one of them
actually go go the full distance and
become a star because there's not many
seats at that top table especially in
the UK so from your perspective which is
a unique perspective what is it that's
separating them I think I think it's a
concoction of things I think the first
thing of course is always Talent
you've got to have talent or some degree
or Talent even though I'm a I'm a strong
believer in hard work always beats
talent but Talent especially within
music is always one of the key
ingredients vision
is the second thing
and I say the first thing is work ethic
how much you're willing to work how hard
you're willing to go
and then
the fourth and I think someone who
encapsulates this is stormzy
is personality morals and
a sense of vulnerability
I think I think when you look at all of
the most successful artists
for me they allow themselves to become
vulnerable
they allow themselves to be judged they
allow themselves to talk about things
that
a rapper wouldn't necessarily
feel comfortable talking about
I feel like
stormzy he's got the talent he's got
incredible Talent you know in terms of
vision and his work rate unmatched I I
remember doing sessions with stormzy
maybe eight eight nine years ago
recording sessions in the studio
and
I called him and said at least before
like he was massive I called him I said
dude I want to get you on a project I'm
working on can you come to the studio
he's like what time do you need me there
um I said if you get there for 4 P.M
it'd be amazing now I didn't need him
there to six but with me spending as
much time as I have with rappers I'd
always say two hours earlier
so uh
it was five to four he turned up I'm
like you're early he's like only five
minutes I'm not in my head I'm not
always two hours and five minutes but so
he comes in the studio
I was like uh do reverse on this song do
a verse on this song Do A Chorus on this
song normally an artist would be in
there maybe
four or five hours he was in there for
like 40 minutes
done this reverses done the hook I was
like is there anything else you want me
to do I'm like whoa uh nah man with that
attitude with that attitude
and the minute he left that studio I
rang everyone and said this guy is a
superstar he is going to be a juggernaut
because his mindset was just he was so
focused he weren't in there
gossiping drinking smoking he was like
I'm here to a job
I'm gonna do the job to the best of my
ability
and then I'm gonna move on to do my next
job
and to see that
in such a young man I was like wow this
guy's gone and I remember after that
there was a few moments that happened
and he was just out of here I just knew
it there's a few artists like that that
have been on the show or I've met
personally and I've said straight away
even to labels friends within the labels
I'm like if you want to place a bet
that's the guy to play the bill
you can just feel it like it's like
you've either got it or you haven't some
of the things that
these artists have that make them
Superstars are unteachable and they're
hard to see yeah very because no one
would have said that but from my
external perspective when I think about
why stormzy made it I'm thinking I did
that thing in the park with the
freestyle and then you know it worked
with you and then I think and he's a
great rapper yeah but even then there's
a reason why he became a great rapper
and it's it's dedication dedication so
focused no no distractions wretch was
the same
and you know what like when you look at
these artists they're the most
incredible human beings set aside
everything else
they're the most incredible human beings
Geeks you know one of the biggest
rappers in this country one of the most
incredible human beings that I know and
you know if you're looking at it from an
inter entertainment perspective you're
like these guys are gangsters and
they're not they're human beings and you
know their personality their morals
their integrity is a big part of why
they've been so successful because
everybody wants to work with them
everybody likes them nobody ever wants
to say no because they're such good
people
and that's a that's a for me a huge
storm is he is super talented incredible
artist but a huge part of people wanting
to do stuff of him is because he's such
a great person
but you represent all of those things
that you've just described the hard work
the vision the vulnerability the
openness even the body language point
you said yeah like I could turn off the
volume on a fire in the booth and just
watch you oh yeah I get carried away
yeah that's because I genuinely care
yeah yeah and a lot of that goes back to
how many final boots have not come out
yeah if you saw my reaction you'll
notice find the booze really even like
well he's definitely not feeling that
maybe that's where they flocked yeah
maybe maybe I don't know but
I can't you can't I can't just I'm a
showman you know a DJ all over the world
I put a show on but in that environment
that is how I feel the energy is what
makes me become the person I become in
the studio at that moment in time they
say 80 of communication is nonverbal
don't they 100 and I believe that I mean
yeah you can see even K Coke if you just
if I didn't speak English I'd still
black yeah it's like oh this is the
passion the pain in his voice yeah it
was a real moment you come out of jail
yeah yeah just being shot at so he's
like this is my opportunity I am not
letting this slip and he didn't I mean
what a huge moment that was for him as
an artist first time I'd ever heard of
him huge went on to be signed by Jay-Z
off the fire in the booth mad insane I
had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when I was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
if you haven't tried the heel protein
product do give it a try The Salted
Caramel one if you put some ice cubes in
it and you put it in a bowl blender and
you try it is as good as pretty much any
milkshake on the market just mixed with
water it's been a game changer for me
because I'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and I'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where he all fits in my life thank you
heal for making a product that I
actually like
a quick word from one of our sponsors
I've got a tip for all of you that will
make your virtual meeting experiences I
think 10 times better
as some of you may know by now Blue
Jeans by Verizon offers seamless high
quality video conferencing but the
reason why I use blue jeans versus other
video conferencing tools is because of
immersion their tools make you feel more
connected to the employees or customers
you're trying to engage with and now
they're launching one of their biggest
feature enhancements to impact virtual
events so far called Blue Jean Studio I
actually used it the other day I did a
virtual event using the studio which I
think about 700 of you came to TV level
production quality all done by one
person with very little technical
experience on a laptop so if you've got
an event coming up and you're thinking
about doing it virtually check out blue
jean studio now let me know what you
think because I genuinely believe I know
this is an advert and I'm supposed to
say this but I genuinely believe it's
the best tool I've seen for doing really
immersive simple but high quality
production virtual events
at some point you get a call from Apple
yep
tell me tell me about that I mean Apple
for me
you know it was a massive moment in my
life and my career so
prior to me leaving the BBC
I had had offers for a few years before
people just trying to start conversation
about what it would look like with me
leaving the BBC
and you know I've got so many great
memories and made so many great friends
at the BBC and it was such a huge part
of my career and my growth as childish
love and of course to find the booth run
but I got to the point in the building
where I had achieved every single last
thing that I had set out to achieve and
every time I'd achieve a go in there I
set myself a new Target
but I'd run out of targets
in terms of where I could go and what
more I could do and you know at this
time I was doing an average of 200 DJ
shows
a year
um I was doing five radio shows a week I
felt a little bit trapped and for me
what I quickly identified as my next
mission
was I felt
not as easy to achieve while being fixed
at the BBC
so I was like all right what's next you
know and you know of course I took into
consideration at the time how people
were consuming content the age group of
the listeners that were listening to
radio
um the demographic of people that was
listening to radio I felt like it
changed and the way we consume content
to change forever and I felt like
listening to radio was no longer an
appointment
I used to wait
every night it isn't design low I used
to wait everywhere weekend
to listen to Westwood it was an
appointment I wouldn't miss it I felt
like those days had moved on and people
were listening at their Leisure you know
there was no fixed time for you to have
to listen you should listen back anytime
you want on the higher player
so for me I've reached this point in my
life where I was a bit like what's next
I'd always knew what was next I'd always
find something that was next throughout
my journey at a BBC I'll just say all
right I've achieved this this is next
let's work towards that
um I couldn't find one
I really couldn't find one and this was
just after the Drake fire in the booth
because that was something that I worked
towards for years and I'd finally
achieved it and I'm kind of
what's next man and I couldn't find
something that was next I'd never want
to do breakfast
it's not really for me
um
I couldn't see anywhere else that I
fitted within the schedule
so
so
I thought you know what let me call Zane
Lowe because he's the first person from
the broadcast World traditional
broadcast well that's made that jump and
he's done an incredible job of doing so
so I've called him and I've run through
my thoughts with him and how I'm feeling
and doubts that I'd had and he was like
dude like I'd love you to be over here I
love it
um if you've got any doubts or any
concerns
go and speak to Oliver
like Oliver's the big boss uh Apple
music he's like just have a sit down
with Oliver I know you I know what you
stand for I know what you believe in you
spend an hour talking to him
so I was like okay he's like I'll set
the meeting up so he set the meeting up
with Oliver I sat down with Oliver he's
like you know okay so what are you
trying to achieve I said I want to be
part of the story
for
the first
British rap artists
to become
a global brand
so in the same way you know Drake did
for Canada which people
20 years ago would have laughed at you
for would have laughed at you the
biggest rapper in the world is Canadian
no way and I feel like that's how people
have fought about a British rapper
becoming a global brand and for me being
a part of that story
um helping that British artists
to whatever capacity that I could but
having a platform and a network that
would enable me to do that was so
important just to be a part of the story
um he was like whatever you need I can
help you you know he spoke about his
passion and his belief and what
motivated him and inspired him and like
we had a very similar Outlook and for me
I was like you just get it like I left
that room and I was like I know apple is
where I want to be I don't care who's
offering what it was there was better
offers on the table I'm like nah he's a
guy I will follow this guy on his
journey and make his journey a part of
mine and vice versa I know that he gets
this he understands what's happening in
the world of content and I'm willing to
jump on this train and that was it and
then from there
you know we've achieved some incredible
things I feel I feel like that we've
been doing things that nobody's ever
done find a booth being uh an asset that
lives on a DSP on Apple music that
people can stream the the the legals
that we had to get around to create this
template of how that looks
now everyone should I do it everyone's
trying to do it and everyone's trying to
work out exactly how we got around all
of the hurdles that we had to get over a
lot of people will ask because it seems
quite
amazing that you managed to take far in
the booth from the BBC yeah to Apple
you'd think that that would be like
their intellectual property or something
yeah so I owned final Booth before I
even went into the BBC and luckily for
me because the BBC didn't have the same
faith in the brand as I did
they didn't invest any money into the
brand whatsoever which would have made
things a little bit more messy I feel
like on my exit if they had invested
into the brand you're right though if
they didn't put money into it then it
becomes uh well look you know yeah yeah
it would become a lot Messier but there
wasn't a contract but it was just you
then invested so you could yeah so
basically there was no side deal okay
per se for finding a booth it was
something that I just did within the
show okay they didn't pay me extra for
firing a boost it didn't provide me any
stuff you're in the copyright I did oh
okay so I've always been up on stuff
like that okay good before I went in
there yeah I owned the full copyright
and then all the trademarks and so I was
like I was up on it and there was
nothing they could do so when I did
decide to leave it was like
cheers thanks I mean I know that
probably button him yeah you know I have
I still have good relations with a lot
of the people in there and they're like
fair play you know you're one of one of
a few that I've got out of the building
with their IP and then you took that to
Apple I took it to Apple
so now I license the brand license it
okay yeah to Apple makes sense smart
it's important conversations because
again we talked about information yeah
and people not having information yeah
it's you know ownership people talk
about ownership
and I feel like the the conversation
around ownership sometimes gets a little
bit cloudy and a lot of people take
the wrong information out of the
importance of ownership
I feel like you know
it's like any business
you can own a hundred percent
of a business
and it'd be worth
you know or even own
two percent of a business that's worth a
billion pounds like I know what I'd
rather own so the understanding of
ownership a lot of people think when
when you say make sure you own
everything they think you're talking
about you owning a hundred percent of
everything rather than
actually owning
the brand you know like find a booth I
own 100 of Friday booth
but I feel like the conversation
generally just gets a bit cloudy because
people don't understand what the
importance of ownership is
on the point of ownership there's a
bottle sat behind me on the Shelf I'm
gonna go grab it
I mean first of all you've engraved this
with the diver CEO so it's of course
just for you it's never getting open I'm
hoping I'll get one of those Diaries
trade-off one of these ones here we have
one here
a lot of people you know that get
involved in the music industry don't end
up starting companies like this
especially companies that are truly
legitimately successful yeah what is the
story of au vodka and why did you start
this business and also let's start this
by just giving me an idea of how
successful this has been so far
wow so we last year we outsold Gray
Goose twice over you're joking no yeah
it's all Gray Goose in the UK twice over
three times as many bottles of Ciroc
um we're on schedule to turn over uh 80
million pounds this year Jesus Christ
yeah so I mean yeah you know we're we're
the top setting premium vodka in the UK
and
we've recently started to really focus
on export we sold out in the states we
just launched in the states last week
and we decided to go state by state we
sold out in two days in the states saw a
significant amount of balls in the
states
um so yeah I mean the story with au
vodka
interesting story actually so
um I had just come off the back of
having this massive Vape business that I
set up years ago Vapes so I remember
being in a club and
um everyone was smoking Vapes and I was
like what is everyone smoking long story
short invested in the company
made a significant amount of money
selling these Vapes sold the business
very quick very quick transaction
and I was like what's next so I was like
no one's got their own vodka business
and I'm looking at some rock I'm looking
what did he's doing over there I'm not
these guys are so ahead of the game The
Americans in terms of branding in terms
of creating businesses in the culture
and lifestyle and understanding how to
navigate that brand and Target a certain
demographic the hard to reach
demographic the the demographic that
marketeers all over the world spend
significant amounts of money trying to
penetrate every year
I have access to that market
and I understand how to position things
in the marketplace so I need to find a
vocal so I ended up spending I spent I I
spent way over a hundred thousand pounds
developing this brand and I just weren't
happy with it I was like
the ball's not right the name's not
right the Liquor's okay I was like it's
not right
so um
I was like all right cool I kind of put
that on the on the back burner for for a
couple of months I need to focus on some
other stuff
two days after me having that thought
I'll put that in the back button I'll
get a DM
on Instagram
and it's from Au vodka and you know
they're a few months old
just not really find their foot they're
like Charlie can we send you some
bottles of a u vodka
and I never respond to messages like
that I just don't I'm not in it I don't
want gifting I'm not into that stuff so
I was looking at the page let me just
check these guys page out vodka I've
been trying to do my own thing I go on
the page and I see the bottle
I'm not whoa these guys have hit the
nail on the head
so at the end back I was like hey you
guys got a number
um there's like yeah cool sent me a
number of I called him I was like hey
what's up man bottle is incredible
I was like what's the story and they
start speaking to me I you know two
friends from swans who've just kind of
set it up it's pretty new I was like you
guys need investment
and I was like nah we don't and I'm like
you don't need any money and it's like
nah we're good so I was like all right
cool I was like well
if that changes this is my number I'm
more than open to a conversation I'd
love to take you guys for dinner
so now all right cool thanks Charlie
yeah hopefully we'll speak again soon so
two weeks later
I'm at the BBC I'll get a call I always
finish the meeting in town would you be
up for grabbing a coffee
how's that of course so I meet the two
Lads uh Charlie and Jackson we go for a
coffee at Nero's coffee just under the
BBC and of course because I've been
working on this project of my own in the
background I've already got my five year
plan
I've got it
written out step by step to a T so I sit
with these guys and I'm like what's the
story so he started talking to me and
telling me about their backgrounds and
how they got into it and why they got
into it and
um I was like look I've got a five-year
plan that I know
we will destroy with this product
we'll make this the biggest thing since
last breath
and I feel like they believed in me in
the same way I believed in them now when
I invested into the business
of course the product was incredible and
I believe that we could do so much with
this product especially within the urban
community
um which I feel is the community that
drives pretty much everything in terms
of Lifestyle these days and when you
understand that I feel like it gives you
a different view on why things work and
why things don't
um so spending time with them getting to
know them I was like these guys are so
hungry and so switched on
I would be honored to be their partner
so we've done a deal we had The
Five-Year Plan you know the plan was
very simple yet very well thought out
like step by step we went through that
plan and we achieved every single last
thing that was on the planet now when we
set out on this journey
we had all agreed that
within five years we'll sell the
business for a hundred million pounds
and we're like great bit of business you
know
pre is in four years in
but like set it for a hundred million
like what you know like uh
our vision changed somewhat
um and the success that we achieved from
this plan that we put in place
we all believed together that we would
achieve this and all of us brought
something different to the table
how much do you think this is valued at
now this company
um I think by the end of this year
realistically
um
if we was doing a 10 times multiply
you'd be looking at 800 800 million I
think with some of the activations that
we have going on
at the moment I'd like to think by this
time next year would be a unicorn
for anyone that doesn't know what
unicorn is yeah uh a business that's
valued over a billion
um and I feel like
we're on
we're on the right track to achieve that
by this time next year everyone
listening to you know this this idea of
a plan yeah is gonna say Charlie listen
I wanna I wanna pop off too I want to
build a business what's the what are
some of the key things that I need to
know about that particular plan when you
look back in hindsight go that's why
this worked out I think like for me the
most important thing
said in anything is understanding your
audience even firing the beef right yeah
even find a booth and this goes back to
branding and my understanding of
branding and my interest and Fascination
in branding
I've always understood the power of
branding and I've always understood
that in order for you to sell something
you have to understand who you're trying
to sell it to seems much easier for you
because you've always been the audience
yeah yeah well I think I think that's
why I'm in a privy position in life
especially with the brands that I
involve myself in I understand the
culture I understand what's acceptable
what's not acceptable what's cool what's
not cool I understand how to speak to
that audience and I also understand that
that audience speaks to everybody else
and you know people try and
pivot away from it no it doesn't work
like that it does work like that the
hard to reach young black audiences
around the world set Trends Ace as
simple as that whether it be fashion
lifestyle they're the translators
they're the people that are cool they're
like if you wear you know you might wear
a jacket a rapper might wear a jacket in
a video that's no one's ever seen it
could be a brand I mean everything that
I'm wearing now maybe the exception
being for the top which has real
Heritage and people have worked with
different things but people in my world
notice because a rapper's worried and
the same for my trainers or the jeans
like even the the Indie kids or the
dance kids will be inspired by fashion
from the urban space so I think
understanding your audience for me
is one of the most important things and
I feel like we understood who we were
trying to set it to so it made it a lot
easier selling it to the audience now
for me a big thing was making it feel
like it was organic
natural and not forced like the worst
thing for me was for it to feel
corporate or to feel like it was part of
the old God so for me it had to be as
disruptive as possible like one of the
things that I did which at the time
you know a lot of people would have been
like what's the point in that but I
understood the implications that I would
have
two three years down the line I
shouldn't really give this as a gem away
but I'm going to give it away because
it's done now we've done it so I wanted
to align the brand with success it's a
gold bottle it's a trophy I wanted
people to feel like that I wanted people
to hold the bottle and feel like they
was holding a trophy
so we we sat down me and my partners and
it was like how how do we do this how
can we achieve that we don't have much
money to spend
we have to make this feel natural and
organic
so what we did is we partnered up with
grm
and I said every time you give away a
plaque
to one of these artists who's achieved
something incredible on your channel can
you give them a bottle of value
yeah cool
so every time these artists were getting
a plaque they would hold their plaque
and hold a bottle of a you
now for everyone else
who's watching this content
straight away the information that
they're getting every time they watch
these videos or series photos is that
their favorite artist who's just one
or had the massive achievement is
holding a bottle of a you every time
it's happening so straight away You're
aligning that bottle
with success and cost us
hardly anything it cost us a bowl each
and every time it happens Jesus but the
implications that that had on people
subconsciously aligning the bottle with
success
I mean Priceless absolutely Priceless
and I feel like a lot of things that we
did the the most significant things that
we did were all Shadow marketing doing
things that people are not really even
paying attention to so yeah if you go
back five years ago and you'd look at
some of our marketing strategies and how
we went about
implementing these strategies
it's like wow okay like you can see it I
could I could tell you the whole story
and then you can go back and actually
see
how we apply these strategies to make us
generate the interest and desire
in the bottle that we have today you
know like we've had huge people do it
now like in your face oh hey you I love
this but I don't feel like those things
are half as impactful as the things that
we've done earlier on in the Brand's
lifespan planting those seeds planting
No Seeds yeah
that's all it is is planting those seats
you know when I started this podcast it
was to hear stories like this about
businesses and successful people and how
they'd risen and stuff and I think the
reason why I called it the Diary of a
CEO as well was because
I don't feel like we spend enough time
talking about the other side of the coin
which is like some of it we've talked
about already today which is the
self-doubt piece the struggle piece like
if I was to look in Charlie's Charlie's
diary and I could read some of those
days where he had written in their
things and you know he was being
completely honest because he didn't
think anyone would see it you talked
about self-doubt you talked about
anxiety playing a role in your career
from this from the jump what are the
things that I would see in that diary
that it's not typical for a boss a CEO a
successful person to be talking about
there will be a lot of
conversation with myself
about balance
I think that's one thing that I've
always struggled with
um in life balance between my personal
life which I keep very personal
for a reason you know I don't I don't
ever want people interfering in my
personal life or passing judgment on my
personal life because it's my personal
life and I keep it personal for that
reason
um but obviously
I've spent a lot of my adult life
working and traveling the world which
means I haven't got to spend
time with my loved ones in the way that
I'd like to and I've got a lot better at
it you know over recent years I've got a
lot better at it but
I feel like that's always something
throughout my career
that I've questioned myself over balance
have I spent enough time being a father
have I been the best father that I could
possibly be
I might be in a good example to my
children you know and
I feel like I said I've got a lot better
at recent years recent years of being a
father and spending more time and
finding that balance I've always been a
good father I've always been there for
my children I've always you know I've
never missed one of my kids birthdays or
you know you know big moments or score
what have you but I just feel like I
could have spent more time being a
father and I balanced it out with myself
knowing that everything I do ultimately
is for them like you know when I'm not
here and what I'm like I think there's a
misconception of me
that
I'm always spending money um I'm quite
um loud with
what I do but I don't really spend money
ow
very little
and everything that I do earn it goes
into a trust for my family so when it
all is said and done you know
they won't ever have to experience some
of the things that I've experienced in
life and they've got a head start and
knowing my children and how grounded
they are and you know such beautiful
children never ask for anything
I think that's one of my proudest
achievements
um but yeah I I question myself a lot
about balance and it rings very true to
me because I this is It's the number one
thing I go back and forth on I've said a
couple of times and hear that just
I almost worry that I'll regret in
hindsight getting that wrong and
sometimes I don't want hindsight to tell
me yeah because it'll be the hard way
won't it same thing for me and I I I I
fight myself over it a lot like am I
gonna
you know get to 60.
be a billionaire but live in regret that
I didn't spend as much time with my
loved ones
as I potentially could have all cards on
the table here as well
I know I don't have kids yet but I've
I'm you know I'm in a relationship I'm
committed so it's the you know the next
natural thing that we both want in our
lives I know that when I have kids if I
don't change something I will say well
all of this stuff is helping them
yeah I mean that's an excuse coming up
to myself I think most people do yeah
you know like
I genuinely believe that
and a big part of my motivation
from the moment my son was born was that
he will never have to experience the
things that I've experienced and of
course when he's living in the shed he
was way too young you don't remember
that when I say it to him now he's like
what are you talking about dad you know
I'd I'd drive him past sometimes like
you used to live in there well this this
goes to a point that I was that someone
said on this podcast to me one day they
said
kids don't care about that stuff they
just care about quality of course they
do they do and that is the biggest
fight of my career balance finding
balance finding time to spend
quality time with my loved ones those
that ultimately I
tell myself I'll do this for do you
think your career is like validating you
making you feel accepted in a way that
you might not have when you're younger I
used to constantly seek validation
constantly
like I feel like especially growing up
where I did you know even going back to
the comments that I made on that show
being on bravado and talking about stuff
that I didn't actually do but I'm trying
to be trying to fit in I'm trying to be
cool I think I shed that
you know at the same time I did when I
felt inferior at times in those board
meetings when I was worried about people
looking down at me
I feel like I don't feel like that
anymore I'm not I'm not trying to fit in
a test here then this is what I I said
to my assistant literally this weekend
when we were chatting with chat in the
kitchen because I was saying you know I
think I'm a workaholic and then I sat
here with this trauma expert and I think
you helped me figure out why I'm a
workholic if I said to you now all your
goals are complete you've done your
to-do list your goals are complete
you've done it I've said Charlie it's
Pina Cola at a time the aircraft's
waiting you go into the beach to relax
no work how would you feel
do you know what
this is funny because
during the first lockdown
when it was like stay at home can't
leave no work it was the first time in
over 10 years diet stopped
diet literally stopped
and for me
I can't explain the anxiety
fear the confusion
I was like so what I just stay here and
do nothing yep you just sit in your
house and do nothing I mean I I don't
understand that
and for the first two weeks
I enjoyed it so much
I was just with my family was doing cool
things I was like this is amazing this
is what life's about
week three
I'm sat there
tapping my fingers I'm like right
like this this ain't life
like I'm not ready for this life yet so
we ended up traveling
me and my family around the world
go into different places that hadn't
fully locked down yet
find them things to do
creating an adventure to keep me
occupied and making the fun part of what
we was doing
finding a place where we're not
restricted
we we did that for several months and
ended up in Dubai
where I could work
where I could DJ and where I could
operate and do business deals freely
we're not spending seven months there
so
answering your question if I was
presented with that opportunity now and
you said to me
everything's done
we're going to sell a you for a billion
we're going to sell find a boo for 50
million uh you know your portfolio of
other things we'll just keep it there
taking over we're going to manage that
throw it all into the trust
no how would you feel I I couldn't do it
but how would you feel give me a word I
have how you'd feel just a word lost
and I guess that what's the opposite of
lost I guess found yeah so that's kind
of what what I was talking to my
assistant about is like my work
addiction which I think I clearly have
is making me feel found it's making me
in some it's validating me it's making
me feel important accepted and whatever
else and I tend to see that often when
people have not always but often when
people have like an early experience
where
maybe they're insecure maybe they had
shame because of where they came from
maybe they had a chip on their shoulder
what they have this unhealthy
relationship where their self-esteem and
their work are so closely linked that
they're not really driven they're being
dragged and I'm being dragged I can say
it because I I've you know I've sat here
with too many smart people to understand
myself like I'm I feel like at times I'm
being dragged too much and I need to
start driving the car not being pulled
by it dude that just hit me
I hit me that's a dude yeah Fair
this is quite the conversation well what
do you think we do
making me reflect on everything that I
thought I knew
well this is the privilege of sitting
with smart people they shine up and
pulled a mirror up to me yeah every day
and I sit here [ __ ] like with
goosebumps sometimes thinking this this
guy needs to at me
how do you reflect on all of that
I mean yeah I feel like it's been a
great conversation and
you definitely
made me leaving here thinking more
even some of the comments you just made
there that ring so true within my
personal life the insecure Steve
insecure Charles is still there you know
and sometimes you know I'm probably
guilty of doing that still to this day I
am yeah that we have a closing tradition
on this podcast where the last guest
asks a question for the next guest
and I don't know what the question is
until open this book
who was the person
who first believed in you
and what do you want to say to them now
I'd say my granddad
was the first person
who really believed in me
and I guess I'll just say thank you
thank you for believing me believing in
me he had like 32 grandchildren
and I was the one I feel like he
thought he saw something in like an
energy or
just a hunger and a desire to be better
I feel like you know yeah he's
he's belief in me made me who I am today
and then I'll say away from my family
group it'd probably be
um a guy who's still part of my team to
this day Arrow calling the coach
you know at a time in my life when
no one believed in me really
everyone just saw me as
a street kid who
didn't really have any prospects or
and I feel like he was someone that saw
past that
I could see that for the first time and
I felt that in my life he was the first
person
who saw past the way I dressed and the
way I spoke and saw me for me
and helped me develop
to become a better person
and focus the energy hunger and desire
that I had
in the right direction
and to him you know he he's still a very
dear friend of mine today
still a part of my team
um has been for
16 years
and again just thank you and you know I
always have these thoughts in my head of
what it looks like when this ends and
how I reward everyone because I do have
an incredible team some you met earlier
and
I wouldn't be able to operate
the way I do without my team I wouldn't
they make sure that
um enabled to deliver the best version
of myself
and I sit there and I think when this is
all said and done
like how do I reward my team
and that's something that I think of
more and more lately
you know as I'm getting older in life
and I feel like there's a few chapters
in my life which will shift in the next
five years
and I think how do I how do I reward
them and show them that I am
grateful
for the time
they've dedicated to me which they have
you know
dedicated to me and believing in my
vision and helping me make my Visions a
reality
and that's one of the hardest things how
do you reward these people that have
enabled you to achieve the things you
have because I'm under No Illusion that
without my team
I wouldn't be who I am today and I
wouldn't have achieved half of the
things that I've achieved delegation was
one of my weakest points
because I just wanted to do everything
and I believed I could do everything and
that's where the whole being child's
love comes from because I did everything
but then as you grow you need to
understand that you can't do everything
you need to stick up what your guda and
allow other people who are better at you
at those other things to come in and
take some of the pressure away and
that's what my team have done and have
allowed me to become who I am so
wow I felt deep for a speech and that's
honestly it's beautiful to hear and I
and again it shows where you're at in
your life that that's the those are the
reflections you're having about paying
it forward your your career has been
that though your career has been
enabling people it's been pushing
forward the UK hip-hop rap scene in a
way like very few that I could ever name
have done getting rappers who didn't
have a platform didn't have a voice from
areas where they were probably counted
out giving them a chance for their
talent to matter above everything else
and that is something that I don't think
you'll ever fully get the credit for
like even though you've got loads and
loads of credit you'll never fully get
the credit for the impact that you've
had in that way I mean that when I was
in Plymouth a kid I was watching all of
those videos when I went up to
Manchester I watched all of those videos
that's where you can name one you know
whether it's all of the rich friends and
I've seen them all yeah I could see your
reaction yeah yeah because I know him I
know that I know I know all of them and
I was there and I had my friends go on
fire in the booth and it was the and it
still is the platform now it's a global
platform but in the UK it was the UK
platform at the time to get to get your
uh to get your brand out there and it's
truly amazing you'll never see that
you'll never see I'm sure Karma will pay
you back in Pleasant ways but I just
wanted to say that to your face while I
have you here thank you and thank you
for your honesty and your vulnerability
and your openness thank you Stephen I
appreciate it it's incredible and it
will help more people than I think you
realize all of it all of it thank you
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]